I don't even know why we're doing this
it's not a duet
Billy you wrote a good song not a great
one
did you guys want to record something or
fight more I'm fine either way
okay let's get this uh started this is
Honeycomb
take one
[Music]
what do you think the song's about what
do I think the song is about what the
song what do I think the song that I
wrote is about
it's about starting a new life
[Music]
it's about dreaming of something
different
[Music]
don't stop
I wanted to tell you look we don't need
to argue
I was just gonna say that I love the
sound of your voice
[Music]
[Applause]
your first single and it hits number one
how do you stop that
[Music]
[Applause]
and you're making an album it's an
intimate thing it has to be I've never
seemed to smile this much in his life
I used to be the first person that could
play things for
is what people want to see it's an act
you know that
tell me that there's nothing going on
between us tell me if I'm crazy
[Music]
if you love her
love her if you ever do that is
[Music]
if you think it's time to add a little
fire don't overthink it I'm the fire
[Music]
foreign